the Joe Rogan experience it's good we
right that's a sativa that stuff's gonna
make you think about space which [ __ ] we
already talked about that [ __ ] I had to
grab myself back cause I didn't wanna go
too far left on the show too far left
too far out Deauville trip in there yeah
and plus I can't articulate it enough
I'm still learning it so in the Bahamas
they probably have very little light
pollution huh don't worry that's why I
say it looks like you have a space X
jokes he came to my house X him that
[ __ ] looks like out of space it feels
like you're the snow globe like when you
are there you see every star when you
were you out there you realize like this
is why people thought about out there
more because before technology at night
that's your problem you have no choice
but to look up there you know that's
what people need to see right yes
when you look up they're like man they
up there like something going on you can
you see [ __ ] going on like I think they
already help their children it's a club
up yeah a club who just people like
nodding like nah no just Kennedy
[ __ ] just chillin like like like
on district 9 and [ __ ]
you see me I think that was the movie
where they had another little space up
there that was that movie you know they
bring tourism down they probably having
tourism up there now they try to do that
to tourism in space yeah yeah that's
gonna happen yeah that's how they're
gonna open up soon oh Jesus
how the [ __ ] would you be able to sleep
when you're hovering over the earth I
wonder how many likes to ever get that
would be like the ultimate Instagram
influencer big booty girl I'd be
alternate pick sticking her ass out and
behind her you see the earth life is all
about being happy I don't buy this this
is 2020 you can go to ISS tummy T you
reap what you sow and tummy TT I've been
drinking this juice and look at must it
is amazing for your hair I mean amazing
what you say what is it the
International Space Station that said
this article
NBC said that there's plans that have
people going there not to stay there but
to go there next year and then uh oh
yeah alright therefore people by 2022
whoa who's gonna be the first to [ __ ] on
drop that Hotel try imma try try I won't
be the first one magic the head rules if
I have a dual cameras that'll be the
first point I do cuz I'm going viral
that day I'm going Instagram laughs and
oh my god not just skeet and just blow
on it you can make nut rings I think
that might be good
tighten up in a bow oh my god you should
be the first to skeet into the air
astronauts and done that before oh no
way they was dead bored up there did
start jacking off you just let that [ __ ]
sceeto I don't think they ever get a
moment whether or not under camera man
who gives a [ __ ] if you [ __ ] much you
think you gonna give up what they gonna
do the you know what you gotta come back
down here this footage somewhere I
promise you we gotta find a cool
astronaut this fine through the air like
a cloud are we still on there yeah oh my
god oh that is funny
[ __ ] that's a good joke to have people
ever has anybody had sex since come on
man but I want to know if it's been
documented they go say
come on people write books wouldn't you
you seem like what you trying to do you
won't be the first mother [ __ ] out of
space ah man I definitely would see it
you kind of have to no official
officially nothing officially correct
but maybe someone has I mean maybe the
Russians say there's not we're not the
only ones to go to space Russians
brought up a vodka and they probably
have orgies up there I'm telling you man
music during the EDM and they've been
[ __ ] on the moon everything I'm
telling is not all on the moon imagine
put where those black we got here
[Applause]